thanks for the introduction so uh
should i should i go ahead
hello uh should i go ahead
yes
yeah okay okay so uh so um some uh i'm
talking from the future 23rd march here
uh and uh
i'm gonna i'm going to talk about uh
robustness of causal identification um
and from the perspective of cause from
from a
from the perspective of a classical
notion in numerical analysis called the
condition number
but before that let me just uh
introduce the notation in a setup i'm
sure everyone here is very familiar with
this but just to make sure we're all on
the same page so i'm going to be talking
in the framework of
of bayesian networks so uh so there's
problem here is that you have some
observed
distribution but observed distribution
really is the marginal on some observed
part of a of a underlying bayesian
network that we don't have full access
to so this classical example from the
work of pearl uh
is about this thing where you will see
that there's a lot correlation between
smoking and lung disease
but then uh
to really say that smoking causes lung
disease you
you have to sort of remove the
confounding effect of any other thing
and this is not just uh
it's not just something that
is theoretical this was actually argued
in court by a lawyer so i think this
person was a lawyer for a particular
company
claiming that there's a theory or
hypothesis that deals with people's
personalities the same thing that cause
people smoke predispose them to lung
cancer so
to get to the point from to get to the
point from here where you see
correlations to here uh where you can
say that smoking causes lung disease you
you typically need to do an experiment
and the question is when can you do
without the experiment can you
can you find can you can you get from
here to here without doing an experiment
just from the
observational data
so uh so the setup the technical setup
for this
is a markov model with some nodes hidden
so there are some some hidden nodes
which we know are there but which we
cannot measure
and the observed distribution
is
you first take the usual beige and
factorization usual visual factorization
on the full graph but then you only
observe the things on the observed nodes
in this case x z and y
uh and you marginalize out the hidden
nodes so that's the observed
distribution that of course does
factorize in some way in this case it's
just a trivial factorization but it's
but yeah because the hidden node is
missing you don't have the full bayesian
factorization
so
and then the question
on the first slide becomes something
like this that you have the observed
distribution which is this full marginal
including this term where the
the dependence of x on the hidden
variable and from this you want to go to
the
go to this which is the in the so-called
experimental intervention distribution
where you
do an intervention so whether you say
whether a person person is smoking or
not
uh without any effect of the genetic
factor or any other hitting factor and
then you want to see whether language
happens or not and that if you assume
that this is the correct physical model
of reality the left
uh is going to be
just uh this here the the
the
uh the the factorization on the right
hand side with the
the
p of x given you removed
and the identification problem is when
is this right hand side expression
computable given just the observed
distribution
so that's the identification problem
uh it's not always possible but
sometimes it is so in particular in the
model i showed you it's one of the first
examples so it's it's where it is so you
can actually get the intervention
distribution from just the observation
so notice it on the right hand side
you only have observed margins things
that can be compared as functions of the
opposite margins and here you have the
two distribution so somehow you you are
able to remove the
effect of you
so uh so the so this problem was studied
for a long time
when it can be done when it cannot be
done the general the goal is that you're
given the graph
you know the locations of the hidden
factors but you don't you don't measure
them and what you want is uh this
algorithm will take the graph the set of
nodes on which you want to perform the
intervention x here the set of nodes y
on which you want to see the response so
this is y and these need not be single
nodes there might be sets of nodes and
what this algorithm should do is output
a symbolic formula
and the symbolic formula should take as
input the observed marginals
and then
output the intervention distribution
which which corresponds to removing all
the incoming edges into the cont into
the intervention variables
okay so so one thing i want to emphasize
is that the goal here was to find a
algorithm that outputs an algorithm so
or a formula so the algorithm itself
outputs a formula that will take as
input the numerical p
the object margin is and then output the
numerical value of the intervention
distribution
uh
so this is a very exact
or logical sort of uh problem and then
there's a numerical part
which comes afterwards of blowing it
plugging in the observed margins and it
took a long time uh to finally come up
with a sound and complete version of
this algorithm the output is formula and
it was achieved in uh so after a long
line of work solving several interesting
special cases or solve solving these two
papers by splitskill perl and one word
um and it does exactly what it says here
so i given a graph it will either say
that such a formula does not exist or if
the formula exists it will output the
formula
and then the formula has to apply to p
as i said to find the final numerical
answer and uh in all of this uh to find
this
formula the graph is known as zoom to be
known exactly and then
to do this computation p the marginal
this marginal table here
is known to is assumed to be known
exactly
so that's that's it
okay so what's a robustness question so
the first
obvious robustness question is about the
numerical stability of the second step
so you have your you have so you have
run this commentary algorithm it has
given you the formula and now you're
going to plug in this p
and but this p is
being measured or
being tampered with in some other ways
so there might be some errors here so
the original actual p might look like
this
and then some digits might be off
and the question is how much do these
small errors how do these errors
propagate as you apply this formula so
that's the first kind of stability
questions you can ask the second
question is about model stability so
suppose that
i mean we had this model uh that and we
made an assumption here and the
assumption was that there is no edge
from u to z that whatever this hidden
factor is it cannot cause star in lines
so if the hidden factor is affecting
what's smoking in lung disease it will
not cause tolerant tar in lungs but
maybe that assumption is not true
and perhaps there is an edge there also
and if that edge was present if that u2s
edge was present then this
identification side this identifiability
goes away then you cannot write down
this id gx5 as a function of p
ah and the idea algorithm would
correctly fail in that case it will just
say that the formula does not exist
but perhaps if the influence of this
edge was somehow weak
maybe we shouldn't be so pessimistic we
shouldn't just say fail and we just try
to quantify the error
of having ignored such a weak edge
rather than just giving up so that the
second kind of stability so these are
the two kinds of stability uh you want
to look at
any questions at this point
if not i have a question can you see my
pointer on the screen or not yes
okay so uh we'll study both of these
notions
using a classical measure of stability
from uh
from numerical analysis which is the
condition number so here i've just
defined it informally so if you have any
function f
and it's being evaluated at some
numerical point p
the condition number is a measure of the
relative error in the computation as
with respect to the relative error in
the input so the you look at that error
in p error in the f of p compared to the
actual value for p compared to the
same kind of relative error in p so p
might be a vector so here i put a norm
so let's not be very uh careful right
now about what norms here and so on but
this is
the rough idea of the condition number
is that you want to quantify the
relative error in the output
in terms of relative area in the input
the precise definition is more or less
the same it looks like this so you
you look at small errors so you have to
look at it in the limit of small errors
and
the relative error is exactly defined as
i said so it's a
error divided by the actual magnitude
and then you look at the relative error
in the output divided by relatively
input in the limit of small relative
error
so why is this uh quantity interesting
and this can be extended component twice
for vectors why is this com uh this
quantity interesting so it's as i said
it's a classical noise in numerical
analysis and it's uh
it can be used it can be justified as a
measure of loss of precision so when
you're doing floating point computation
so
the way i to p754 works so if you use
double or float in any
standard computer language
programming language
the current log of the condition number
sort of measures the number of digits of
precision that are lost when you use
floating point computation
to compute it so it's not like
this is exactly the number of digits
operation loss it's sort of more or less
like a lower boundary than digits
operation that are that are lost so i
won't go into detail here but uh this is
sort of a classical thing and because of
this
interpretation is very well studied
especially in the context of
numerical algorithms in linear algebra
in fact so well studied in that context
that often when people say condition
number what they actually mean is the
condition number of solving a linear
system and you might have seen that as
the ratio of the top and the
bottom singular values
so that is
that definition of
the ratio of similar values comes from
this more
first principles definition it happens
to be that in the case of solving being
systems
and
it's a very rich theory a lot of
numerical algorithms and their
performance can be studied in this
context this is very there's a very nice
book with a somewhat philosophical title
uh by bridges
okay so so this classical notion exists
so what what about it so we can
certainly use it for our purposes we
have a numerical problem and we can try
to see what the condition number is but
just that would not be good enough it
turns out that the condition number in
the case of uh
in our setting in the case of
identification also turns out to be
related to model stability and in
particular small condition number which
is what would mean that the loss of
friction is small in the numerical
analysis
also means that the effect of uh adding
extra weak edges is small
okay
so uh so what this means is from some
previous work is that if you have a weak
edge and a weak edge is given by
uh
by this kind of condition what this
condition is saying is that
if you change the value if you change
the value at the
head of the edge
then the
distribution the conditional
distribution of the tail does not change
much in a relative sense the logs so
instead of logs you can just think of
the ratio being bounded with between one
plus minus one plus minus epsilon
and uh one can show quite easily in fact
that if
you have a graph so you have a graph
like this where which is where x y 2 x
is not identifiable but if you remove
the edge use it then it is identifiable
and further if you know that the edge
that you're removing to make the
modeling fiber is weak
and you also know that the id has small
condition number
then
the value does not quite change so you
can just run id on the
in this
wrong graph which has
the edge removed
and output that as your answer and it
would be still
quite a good approximation to y to x now
at this point you should be suspicious
like g in i said that in g this is this
y 2 x is not even identifiable so what
does this even mean
well it is
not identifiable but it has a definition
in terms of if you knew the full graph
with a hidden variables this value
exists and what this is saying is that
no matter what the hidden variables are
doing if this weak weakness assumption
is correct then all the possible values
of this p of y to x will be close to the
value that you get
by computing almost
so that means that small condition
numbers are good uh not just from the
point of numerical stability but also
from the point of view of model
stability so then the question we ask is
uh what's the condition number of causal
integration uh in the setting so you're
given the graph g the intervention
variables x the kind of the fine the
the response variables y
and
and we want to
find out what the condition number is
okay so i am going to study it in the in
this
generic setting where you
sort of assume that
each variable has a discrete set up and
i have nothing nothing about
distributions at all except that they
follow the bayesian network but if you
are in a in a setting of more slightly
more parameterized setting like
linear structural equation models there
also this notion has been studied so
uh in particular you can see this bit by
some karaman
but i would not be looking at this
setting i would i would work
um completing the setting of uh
variables which where there is no such
parametric assumption
okay so before i proceed i'll just put a
quiz here so here's almost a trivial
model uh what is this trivial model so
there are just two kinds of nodes
the s nodes and the x nodes
and there's a hidden variable sitting in
between each two consecutive s nodes so
there's a hidden variable sitting here
between s1 and s2 and so on between s2
and s3 s3 and s4 and so on so this every
two is one here you know i've removed
the head node i just put the bi decrease
there
and
of course p of x 2 s is identifiable in
this it's
pretty easy to show that pretty easy to
also compute this value
and
the question is what do you think is the
condition number for this
trivial model does it grow linearly
within is it independent of n or does it
have some other behavior and you can
assume that the observed marginal p is
just uniform so let's say you're in a
really trivial setting where the margin
we observe is just the uniform um
distribution and assume that all the s
i's and x are bits and
p is uniform distribution over all these
two inputs
so we'll come back to this question uh
later
so uh this is so just to come to the
result so that uh
[Music]
so uh so the first question we ask is
are there any important classes where
the condition number is small
so so so there are and in particular one
nice class turns out to have not too bad
condition number so the c component so
recall that a c component in a such a
semi markovian model is a
so a c component is a component like one
of these like the yellow one where all
if you just look at the bi-directed
edges which is
the sort of the hidden edges while
ignoring the hidden variables
the c components are the connected
components induced by those by
definitions so in this case a x y w b
are connected because you can go from a
to x x to w to b just following the head
energies so
so that's what a c component is and when
the sizes of all the c components are
small
uh the condition number is not too large
so each uh
your graph of n observe nodes each c
component of size music
uh
when it is for positive p the condition
number
or call the identification for which
the identification identifiability
actually holds
is n times something that depends upon
the size c
so this is not tight uh we'll come to
see later this is not tight but at least
this gives us a bound and this
settings also where condition numbers
are small so in particular uh
this setting which was studied by tian
and perl on the road to the full
identifiability result uh
so this is a setting when x is a single
node and no child of x is in the same c
component as x
so in this setting also
again condition number smaller
there's some at least some simple
settings the conditional based
so so but these are all okay so this one
is probably quite general the smallest
components the second one is somewhat
specific but still it's interesting case
because
it was an important special case to be
solved
but with these results uh the question
we ask is how does an algorithmically
estimate the condition number
so uh
so so this
transfer one can write down exact
expressions for it although those
expressions might be hard to
deal with computationally and uh dealing
with them efficiently is some open is
some open problem for future work but
the result is is this so if you have any
causal graph and positive p
ah such that p of y to x line difference
the condition number can be written in
terms of the gradient of the log of the
function so id g of x y is some is a
remember it's a formula
uh it's a formula whose input is the
probability vector p
so you look at the log of the formula
look at the gradient of that
and you think of the entries of the
gradient
and you assign a weight to each end so
each entry the gradient corresponds to
one of so omega is the
is the domain of
t so p is the probability distribution
uh
with all elements of omega
and uh so the gradient are also indexed
by that and you look at the entries of
the gradient the log of the gradient uh
weighted by p and uh you look at the
expectation of that
uh so you it's sort of there is one like
the l1 variance so the minimizer here
will be the median so you just look at
the median of the entries of gradient
vector but the median is not just the
usual region but with respect to p so as
i said the entities are indexed by omega
each omega comes with weight p of omega
and with these weights you will look at
the median of the entries of the
gradient
and then take the expectation
of the deviation from that
so this is somewhat of a multiple but it
easily for example follows that
[Music]
condition number is therefore also
bounded by the square to the variance of
the entries the gradient again
when you look at the entries as being
sampled from this particular property
distribution
okay
so
so in any questions
okay so so maybe now let's answer the
quiz so
let's take into the next part of the
talk so uh so the quick question
remember was
we had this somewhat trivial looking
model uh
two kinds of nodes s and x s one to s n
and x one two x n there's a directed
edge from each s i to the corresponding
x i and the hidden variable between each
s i 2 each s i to s i plus 1.
so by delta
and we wanted to look at the condition
number for computing
the condition number for computing this
expression which is x probability of x
equal to 0
and on the intervention s all the s
are said to see
so the first
step is to just see that
i mean this is a trivial model so i said
it's trivial so
the identification problem is also
trivial in fact
it's
so trivial that the
id expression is just a conditional
distribution
so the
p of x to s is just p of x given s
but it can also be written in slightly
different form you can factorize it
further using the other
because this model supports more
conditioning dependencies so this is
also equal to
as i goes from 1 to n the probability
that x i equal to 0 given s equal to and
then the product from one
okay so
so now maybe i i can ask the quiz again
squeeze was what are what how does the
condition number grow
so
so it so actually since it's getting
some bounce is not so
difficult so
it's some quite easy to actually see
that the condition number of the first
one here the first expression is
is
is is a constant it's both upper and
lower bounded by a constant that's what
this mutation theta 1 was
for the second one it's also easy to
show that at least upper bounded by n
for order n
about 2 times n
so they are quite different and it turns
out which is maybe somewhat strange that
the correct answer even in this trivial
case
uh is square root n so
so the first one the first expression
the the condition number is constant
second expression the condition number
is about square root
although the trivial things would say
it's about ordering
so even this trivial model the condition
number can behave in somewhat strange
somewhat strange
they and the other thing i want to
highlight is that these two equivalent
expressions are easily seen to be
equivalent in this case
for the id expression
and they have very different condition
numbers one is a constant the other one
is growing within
so uh
so so even this is a trivial model like
this the condition number
seems to uh behave in a very
different way
so
any questions about this
so if not let me before giving the proof
sketches maybe let me just mention a few
uh
a few
future directions before i come to the
proof sketches
so uh
so
so so what we have seen so far is that
the order n condition number and c
compressor of constant size but these
are not tight even that trivial example
showed that and two is a bond in the
condition number for any given instance
and there's some surprise even in
trivial in example that a condition
number may show non-entry to be
available in trivial instances
so
uh so there are many uh
future things here so the expressions i
showed you uh i'll see how i will show
you how they were derived
but the expressions i showed you
they're not so efficient to compute i
mean we can we can sort of do it by hand
in some some examples uh so so the
question of finding more efficient
algorithms approximate the condition
number would be so the idea would be
that given a model as soon as you have
the model you should be able to evaluate
at least some good estimate of its
condition number because that lets you
evaluate both the
the sensitivity of the model to ignoring
weak edges and also the sensitivity to
numerical perturbation statement
and
one
direction in this context that
[Music]
that i think might be quite interesting
is that this some work on
simplifying id expression so the id
algorithm is one algorithm that takes
the graph and outputs a formula for the
intervention distribution we already saw
in even in this trivial example
so even in this previous example that
if
even this trivial example that you can
have to add varied to sort of different
ideas which are equivalent in the sense
that on the manifold of the property
distribution that is supported by their
model
they are equal
but they behave very differently with
respect to perturbations so the
condition number can be very different
for those two
so
so this
so this work on simplifying id
expressions
this could
possibly so condition number could
possibly play a role here so when you
are trying to
define this notion of what is a simpler
id expression
the condition number could be one
parameter to
decide between two different equivalent
id expressions
uh the second uh
question is the second kind of thing so
that where the condition number might
help and which is again open and should
be quite interesting is
that this work on using extra
information so maybe the model is not
identifiable but perhaps if you're if
you are given some more extra
information perhaps you're giving some
other so you cannot do the experiment
that you read so you want to identify
the effect of x and y you cannot do that
experiment but maybe you can do the
experiment of looking at the effect of
some other variable z on y and this work
on trying to use information like this
where you have some extras the
experimental data available on
on putting bounds on the
on some
identifiable or even non-identifiable
intervention distribution so
the question would be that is by using
this extra information which could be in
the form of extra experiments or more
observations
can you read it can you make the problem
more stable
uh so can you change can you
decrease the condition number by using
extra information so this is something
that we have not
looked at so far at all but it looks
very interesting especially given the
work on
this using extra information for
identifiability
okay so uh
so with that i let me just give up
you know about i think three or four
minutes i have uh just a brief sketch of
the proofs
so
so for the
for this theorem uh which gave the
corollary in terms of the variance uh
the proof turns out to start with
something so i just use f for the id
just to keep the notation simple
uh so the
so the sort of the only sort of
interesting step here is to use
some what standard ideas from numerical
analysis but in when you specialize them
to this setting it turns out that you
can write the condition number as a
linear program
uh
and once you have a link so the linear
program might look somewhat unmotivated
but it's just done so that you you can
at least you can get to this form but
once you have a linear program there is
interesting tools one can use in
particular one can use duality and as
soon as you use
so after you've done the hard work of
actually getting to the linear program
just a mechanical process of going to
the dual uh gives you that result and
and the corollary also
so
so this is the second one i will not go
into more detail except that i will just
say that there's some
when you're not trying to be tight so
here we wanted a exact expression for
the condition number we wanted the
equality and tight bounds
but
when you're not trying to be that exact
there's a simple calculus for condition
numbers which sort of looks like the
calculus for logarithmic derivatives so
the condition number product
is the sum of the condition number
condition number sum is max condition
number of composition multiplies and so
on
uh
under certain conditions so for details
you can see
and the this result is sort of based on
using this calculus except that you have
to be a bit careful uh to exploit this
bounded current so
there's no bound here on how many
nodes you're intervening on or how many
nodes you are
looking at the response
so you have to be a bit careful uh in
the induction by using these things but
but that's how the proof goes the proof
sort of tries to use these this this
calculus for condition number throughout
the idea algorithms propagates like
algorithm
carefully to make sure that the c
component side is being handled
correctly
okay and
the one thing i would want to say that
these calculus rules are
the quiz example already shows that so
the calculus rules will tell you that
the condition numbers are at most order
n and the correct answer is square root
n
okay so uh so with that uh let's end
that
thank you speaker again